my guess is that people will sort of
watch their health in a way that's a
little toaster to the way that they
watch the financial portfolios and
things then better might have army Yeah
right but but you know so what happens
in finance for example you can say well
there are these symptoms of what's going
on with some stock it has some wiggle
that looks like this you know if you're
a technical trading you say well that
wiggle looks like you know a
head-and-shoulders effect or something
like this and then you say well given
that well I should buy sell whatever I
whatever I should do you know but in
fact we know that in the finance area
it's much more you know given this
particular behavior we have some
algorithm the algorithm decides what to
do and we go on from there my guess is
that in sort of the medical world it
will be much more like that there'll be
a lot of sensor data that's coming in
you'll see all these curves there'll be
all sorts of detailed effects in those
curves some of which you'll be able to
describe in some sort of easy linguistic
way others of which are just well it's a
wiggle in the curve and there's nothing
particularly to call it the the thing
that and then what will happen is
there's both a certain amount of human
you know looking at these curves that
will happen just like there is an you
know in financial kinds of things but
there's also potentially lots of
algorithms that you get to use to decide
what to do so I'm guessing it will be
sort of sensors in algorithms to decide
what to do potentially algorithmic drugs
and various kinds of algorithmically
oriented medical devices